Lực lượng về bình cách mạnh hủy sau ina thù báo đã khởi động nạn sọt tình công bối
Nhà vật à một tiêu của Israel và Ví trong khu vực, sử dụng là tên lượng và tế bị mây không người lại khi bố lớn.
Quận lỗi đất này trên bố, ná bán bốn tế lợi đàn nào, nhằm và tổ sân bay US,
Amara Ham, Plint Cô Hài Cô Mỹ, một số mấy bây chình đâu của Mỹ đã bị bánh hàng.
Lỉnh vị cũng đã có thêm vào bà bà bà xin.
Cô chiến có thêm nhìn tổ mới khi lượng hết bố là tham chiến bằng loạt loa cân nhằm và thích vô hài phá của Israel.
Kích hoạt loạt không tích or a của quân độ Israel và đủ đô bay đút của Li Bâm.
Như nhé vật các cao của hết bố là là một tiêu của các loạt tình công này.
Cũng theo của độ Israel, mọi vương án, liều đang được kinh nhắc, kể các khá năng vời chỉ sĩ tình công trên bộ và Li Bâm.
Không chỉ tình công và đặc trá, các bê lên quan liên tiếp nửa ra các tuyên bố cân sánh.
Chên một bài đặc trinh mảng giá hội, tự ki hội đồng an ygu sa tự cao ira, a liên là risa đi hình định.
Tên ràm sẽ không đam phán phy nghĩ.
Tổng đúng đúng đồ đơn giáp thị phát đi tỷ điệu rằng, chứng sịch tất công quân sự của Mỹ Israel,
nhằm các các mục tiêu của ira, có thể giao xa trong nhiều tôn cho đến khi Washington đã lực tất cả các mục tiêu lesa.
Cô hỏi đã xa lúc này, không chỉ là dự nhiên quân sự, mà là hệ quả trở lực và pháp li đối chặt từ quốc tế.
Món tất cả liệu của Bètet Phi và Kèn.
Cô về những khu vật đứa bước sang một dây đoạn hoàn toàn khác sau khi có cuộc đầm phản thất mại.
Văn ngôn ngôn ngôn chính trang, xương mọi quân sự quay trở lại.
Đó là một hấp dẫn.
Các cuộc đầm pháp liệu của Bètet Phi và Kèn.
Để bảo vệ anh nình vào liệt, cũng như lãnh thổ và người dân.